cuál es su visión de khan academy en 10
años bueno tendremos 78 millones de
aulas tal vez llegando a mil millones
mil millones cierto o más cambiar la
forma de la enseñanza por algo
maravilloso que transforme en mente y tú
que nos dices el producto se convertirá
en algo que se adapte totalmente de
manera personalizada a los estudiantes y
en 10 años cómo piensas que se va a ver
este ayudar bueno en 10 años volveremos
a ver el día de hoy y diremos
qué tiempos aquellos en que la educación
no era gratuita en la que no se podía
aprender todo lo que quisieras de manera
libre y gratuita en línea y por supuesto
que es personalizada y por supuesto que
los maestros estarán utilizando y será
la manera en la que todos aprendimos y
de alguna manera es como cuando
volteamos hacia atrás y en la época que
no teníamos teléfonos móviles y decíamos
cómo nos comunicaríamos o tal vez en los
80s cuando no había computadoras
personales o utilizarlas y utilizar el
internet bueno tal vez luego pensemos y
recordemos y toda esta tecnología pero
no lo estábamos útil
de la manera adecuada se convierte en
obvio se convierte en obvio y tú schalke
dices bueno yo iba a empezar diciendo
que íbamos a alcanzar a 100 millones de
estudiantes pero ahora me he quedado
corto ya veo que estoy en la cota baja y
no soy tan ambicioso halt bueno pero
diré que al menos 100 millones de
estudiantes alrededor del mundo y en
todos los idiomas de mayor importancia y
será una experiencia sumamente amplia
enriquecedora desde aritmética cálculo
álgebra y también será una experiencia
muy profunda
utilizando simulaciones de manera que
los maestros también exploren e
interactúen con khan academy y llegue el
momento en el que ya no tengamos estas
aulas sin ventanas en los que un
profesor atiende a 30 alumnos y
transformarlo en espacios más abiertos
en donde los estudiantes pasen digamos
el 20% de su tiempo estudiando en tan
académico y el resto de su tiempo lo
dediquen a pintar a construir robots o
tal vez escribir guiones de película